den kompletten bau mit dem pack ich da
einmal pflanze ich dann mal oben drauf
und fertig es ist dunkel im wald
alkohol hat will ich euch einfach an tun
er ist so cool finde ich ganz das noch
mal sagen ich fand das voll cool noch in
hama jorge armee der hammer schlechthin
ja schöner gewesen wenn du vielleicht
nicht in meinem zimmer schlafen würde
sobald ich mehr
ach da kann ich ihn töten ein bisschen
nämlich sofort bei deinem bett 1 es
läuft nein du dreist ist oder ich bin so
behindert ich tu dir doch noch ein blog
rein
naja ich bin wieso willst jetzt schlafen
schlaf gut habe süße träume wenn er
immer noch dafür dass wir uns immer noch
dafür dass du jetzt endlich mal das ding
ja fertig machst du musst da kisten
reinsetzen und anpassbar neues thema hat
eigentlich schon gemacht aber ich habe
einst es sind also fragen immer diese
frage nicht mehr macht zu fragen hirsch
posten
ihr seid ihr seid alle voll cool
kommentar frage von mandy brand
kommentar frage warum baut den nc ein
halbes jahr allein sein an seinem haus
hall besonders schlimm da schon mal
gelogen habe stets um kommentare locker
schon drei jahre keine glasscheibe
nutzen glas dienstrecht die schöner
finde
willst jetzt irgendwas als tür da machen
ja zwei türen die musst du dahin setzen
welche beide also so holzstühlen weil
ich finde ich relativ fest bevor jemand
setzen wie tnt darunter ein jahrhundert
waren aus meiner kraft kurz vorstellen
vorstellen ja ich bin ja immer noch am
hin und her laufend dauernd mandala dorf
down so erna berg doch jetzt allerdings
dem vorschlag von mister petersilie
themen verstärke doppelpunkt
energydrinks ab 18 jahren
eure meinung zwölf damen hoch wo ein
energydrink gestorben jetzt diskutieren
wir alle über das thema gemacht dass ich
kein bock drauf weil man ein natürlich
müssen jetzt darüber diskutieren
das war ja so dass in nordamerika sind
ein oder zwei personen an den konsum von
energydrinks stoppen weil dort übermäßig
koffein drin enthalten wir noch andere
substanzen gar nicht so genau weil ich
mir darüber nicht wirklich informiert
habe obwohl da wirklich so viele darüber
berichtet haben aber es war wohl so dass
diese marke dieser hersteller dieser
produzent haben die haben wohl
summen überschritten oder ich weiß gar
nicht ob es diese summenbegrenzung diese
resistenz begrenzung in amerika bob gibt
die wir hier in deutschland haben
jedenfalls haben sie die überschritten
blabla und deswegen diese leute die das
rezept kinder jugendliche bei sich hat
gar nicht sind dann halt davon haben wir
von euch irgendwie was hatten sie
herzinfarkt glaube ich herzstillstand
irgendwie so war sich jetzt wird nur
stören weil wegen raum weil wegen viel
zu viel zucker und so aha und keine
ahnung jedenfalls ist das wohl nicht so
gut gewesen jetzt sagen alles verboten
werden sagt jetzt natürlich ganzen
eltern und zweitens fort aber ich finde
eigentlich dann müsste man auch alkohol
verbieten finde ich weil auch wenn du zu
viel alkohol trinkt denn dann kann es
auch sein dass du davon stirbt weil du
dann in eine lebererkrankung bekommst du
ihm gesagt also soweit ich weiß es ja
nur eine und ich weiß dass mehrere sind
aber jetzt der letzte fall weil der das
ganze eigentlich glaube erst zum staaten
gebracht hat dass irgendeine mädchen
irgendwie glaube ich nur zwei dosen
getrunken hat irgendwie 2 also insgesamt
1 liter und dann herzstillstand bekommen
hat aber da das jetzt ja eigentlich
nicht so passieren kann weil ihr glaube
ich jede menge diese mengen und oder
noch mehr am tag trinken schlecht ist
immunsystem oder wie ja also ich hab das
aber auch nichts davon gelesen dass die
irgendeine herzrhythmusstörungen so was
ähnliches schon hatte aber das ist ja
ich das logisch ist eine vorerkrankung
gab und dass jetzt vor allem in
deutschland wo es schon total strenge
richtwerte gibt wie viel da drin sein
darf wie finde ich also grenzwerte mehr
als noch nach einem verbot oder erst ab
18 jahren dass das so gefordert wird
also hoffe ich
ja wenn ich immer alles verbieten
anstatt irgendwie aufzuklären oder sowas
das wäre weniger statt einfach verbieten
verbieten aber jedem das meine meinung
deine meinung ist auch kleinstadt
verbieten
meine meinung ist gar nichts machen aber
ich mag die energie fink selber nicht
also dann geht mich das generika also
mal kammern energydrinks trinken wenn
man irgendwie also es wird ja auf partys
ziemlich oft wirklich energy bin ich
energy mit wodka teilweise gemixt aber
ich finde jetzt eigentlich was gibt's
denn da es gibt ein monster finde ich es
eigentlich so mit der leckerste
es gibt aber auf den den habe ich jetzt
seit 12 monaten nicht mehr getrunken
weil ich weiss nicht jetzt ist wirklich
einfach nur süß
das kann man mal machen aber sonst dann
auch wieder nicht weil ich kann jetzt
jeden tag sein ding da trinken um ihn
wie wach zu werden vor der schule
eröffnet ist einfache weise nicht das
metier zu süß muss ich einfach so sagen
also ich denke auch dass wenn man dann
bist du so weit weg bis zum haus nun
habe ich das gar nicht mal wieder hier
bei meiner top cut am werkeln bis acht
die gibt es ja nicht mehr
du kannst du gleich mal couples tonnen
hering für die handlichen
das macht etwas anderes also ich trinks
allgemein ich und ich denke auch nicht
dass man so was verbieten sollte welche
meinen wenn sie wirklich ende daran
gestorben ist dann muss es eine
vorerkrankung sein weil du sonst
normalerweise von seinem getränk wenn du
nichts hast nicht sterben kannst es geht
einfach nicht das heißt die muss
irgendwo herkommen gehabt aber darüber
muss sie auch informiert gewesen worden
sein
jetzt wird ihr dieses unternehmen von
den relativ wenig wie viel geld werden
die verklagt ich habe den usa so
riesensummen mehr als millionen auf
jeden fall
naja fast fertig nur fünf minuten
ich bin dabei noch türen zu kräften
das sind jetzt immer schon teilweise
sachen von mir unten im lagerraum und
andere noch nicht und muss ich immer so
bisschen hin und her schauen was schon
unten ist was nicht unterscheiden ist es
unten das heißt officer unten und unten
habe ich keine kraft inc
wir müssen auf jeden fall was offen will
ich da vielleicht hin tun und eine
crafting mensch aber wo soll es hingehen
anschauen weil das irgendwie relativ
ungeordneter er so klein
im sinne von da passt es irgendwie
schlechthin alles jojo ist doch
eigentlich eine eisen rüstung oder was
das du an
ich habe noch ein jahr
mehr habe ich ja nicht steine version
gibt es nicht ist das lokal in höhlen
slomka war wie so eine kirchenglocke
kirschen kirche wie sie ohne küche ob
ich start gehabt so ich wollte etwas gab
es noch nicht getan
blöd ich wollte holzofen glaube ich oma
nächste total verplant keiner bestätigen
dann tue ich hier ein glas durch da
rheinwiese schaufeln getan
heute verstehe es nicht
das thema energy drinks ab 18
weil das thema nicht mehr trinken darf
dass meine wenn sie natürlich setzen
dann dauert es noch ein bisschen unter
das thema zurzeit eigentlich fast gar
nicht aktuell swayze war aktuell waren
am 18
es wurde auch glaube ich vor allem in
deutschland diskutiert nicht nur in den
usa sondern oder ich weiß vielleicht war
es auch nur das avm diskutiert aber
erstmal bin ich also auf ihr fahrrad an
die präsidenten läuft nichts dazu gesagt
weil wir oft gehörten ja und da werden
ja auch nicht gewählt wenn wir das
verbieten man von den ganzen unter
18-jährigen die erwähnen dürfen
südamerikaner trinken übels viele diesen
schwachsinn
bisher war von verbot werde nur über
18-jährige betroffen und über 18 jährige
wählen also nur die nur unter 18
jährigen betroffen aber die unter
18-jährigen die wählen ja nicht löscht
ja trotzdem ist es irgendwie doof mit
einer negativen mit einem verbot zu
werben
naja für besorgte eltern die über nacht
zu gering ist es vielleicht teilweise
egal und so irgendwie besorgte eltern
wären dann so ohl ja sehr gut
das könnte ja sein
also ich schaue mal das haus an da
bisher steht da eine kiste drin war und
da es nicht mehr was drin
doch das was dann ja in die andere
kisten von dir kommt ein pass tags und
sollte vor allem sagen wo dann offen
soll und wo das crafting manchmal ein
ofen eine crafting menschenrechte gerne
rein tun ja ist doch scheiß egal wohin
irgendwo beim innert drei minuten weil
ich ja wenn die einfach im boden stellt
da werde ein bisschen dumm
ich kann es auch hier irgendwo auf dem
weg stellen dass sie aber scheiße aus ja
da in das gebäude mit rein
neben die kiste sie aber doof aus wachs
teilt über die kiste auch doof denen das
haus sieht scheiße sitzt sondern dienst
jetzt egal
gute crafting bensch und noch ein ofen
am allerpark ist noch eine kiste hin
mein gott macht ich nein noch nie kiste
siri die scheiße aus ich mach's doch
jetzt schon machen
moment da crafting table dahin sorgen
jetzt mache ich noch mal schnell und
offen
holz würde sich die holz musste er noch
in die andere künstlerin ist bisher noch
besonderen preis das meinte ich hier
sollte körpers habe ich aber nichts dann
holz mehr schnell kurz ein paar bäume ab
da aber darin dem anderen walter machte
daneben kommen wo bist du ja daher muss
das essen nämlich sprinten kann
so haben wir dort eine schweinefarm
beziehungsweise wie viele schweine
sentieren aber wir haben da ganz hinten
schweizer das heißt wir müssen die
einfach überholen ist das effektiv sinne
ersten mäßig m und will's holz vorher da
können wir jede menge holz ist ja auch
egal welche farbe ist jetzt vor allem
wenn sie so allgemein holz brauchen
welche art nicht welche farbe beide ist
das gleiche ich will keine schwarze bei
mich fällt nur weiße beim rassist so
alles weg sagt das ist dass jeder
vielleicht 16 hat oder sowas dann wurde
dass wir insgesamt steckt haben schön
aber jeder kann seine holzresten
schreien schmeißen so stix und sowas
insgesamt 1 tag also ich hab jetzt schon
insgesamt 27 ja dass du also 32 hast ich
habe 24 ich habe gerade 34 so ich packe
meinen dass schnee noch den einbau mit
und dann nimmst den kompletten bau mit 3
dann packe ich doch einmal pflanze ich
noch mal oben drauf und fertig alter
warum ist es bei dieser droge bei mir
egal war eine schöne folge mit 100 ps
mein haus steht jetzt leider nicht mehr
sondern noch so ein kleines ding
es war ein erfolgreicher aufnahme das
haus von craft da ist zunächst daran
vielleicht einmal den wald ausleuchten
wir jetzt echt ziemlich finster nehmen
sollten überhaupt überall wo einst
häuser stehen so überall auszuleuchten
dass hier keine monster überhaupt
bauen können und dass dann insgesamt um
zäune mit wir hier keine krippen sowas
fürchten müssen ja um zwei entfernt ich
auch ganz gut so
ich hätte zugetraut hast du das wär was
nimmst es so ich dir zu trauen ach ja
ist ja egal hatte ein paar andere sachen
leder das kann ich instinkt chancen
das läge so gut dann würde ich sagen wir
bedanken uns für 100 für die aufnahme
trat auf seinem kanal vorbei
vielleicht hatte er den patienten lp und
schreibt in den kanal kommentare
herzliche grüße von utopia und
energydrinks verbieten erlauben würde
unter 18 und lasst ihr denkt wer der
nächste gast sein wird
er wurde bisher wurde jeder gast dem wir
haben oder davor stand in den
kommentaren bitte soll die xxl der und
er kommt erst mal und die nächsten gäste
stand auch schon in kommentaren gelesen
ehrlich ja also beide wie stadtrand
schon drin denn kommt eine tasse komfort
ach scheiße damm herrscht skepsis auch
schon drin ja auch schwach
aber william johnston stand noch nicht
drin
davon weiß ich gehe mal noch beim
management abgeklärt darum wer managen
was mit bis zu digitalen abgekehrt egal
gut
wir sehen uns dann in der nächsten folge
wenn es wieder heißt die gelbe welle
dies machen wir ins stadthaus und da war
doch dazu sind regt sich morgen ein
stadthaus
das großartigste an der ganzen volkes
dass es hässlich aus der hässliche ec
wahrung von crafter endlich der
vergangenheit angehört ein hip hip hurra
die kommentare dann dafür soll gehört es
das was wir bisher in dieser folge
geschafft haben ist eigentlich nur
negatives weil wir haben zwar diese
stadt ausgebaut darf es mein haus weg
und dein boden war weg und alles
mögliche
also wer mehr sagen auch gut gemacht als
dass wir hin gebaut haben aber egal sein
was irgendwie eine interessante hause
lag mir eine interessante witzige folge
app bis zum nächsten mal thema hip hip
hip hip hurra